au tour de france cycliste troisième
étape vire pomellec en bretagne
vainqueur l'allemand zabel hausse prix
italien ciccolini conserve le maillot
jaune
mais l'événement du jour c'est l'abandon
à la suite d'une nouvelle chute du
peloton de l'un des favoris le suisse
toni roaming françois brabant
il doit rester 10 km jusque là c'est une
étape sans histoire et tout à coup
apparemment sans raison y'a comme un
trou dans le peloton pour la deuxième
fois en quatre jours
ils y achètent collectif sur le tour au
bas d'une descente sur une portion de
route partiellement gravillonnée vélos
des coureurs se retrouvent en mêlée
parmi eux un seul ne se relève pas pour
repartir
tony roaming est le champion suisse
leader de l'équipe cofidis de cyrille
guimard s'est fracturé la clavicule et
ç'aurait pu être pire
il est tombé sur la tête c'est la veille
parce que la gauche qui était
complètement cassé quoi est donc là le
casque cassé exploser car il avait la
chance d'avoir un casque je crois ce qu
elle était carrément fait dé son côté et
donc non il avait la clavicule qui était
bien on a vu un petit peu qu'on était
bien bien fracturé bon il avait un petit
peu la jambe raide et le coup et bien
sûr des plaies encore up le bitume
points à 36 en roaming guère disputé
cette année ce qui devait être son
dernier tour et il avait bien commencé
quatrième au classement général ce soir
son tour s'achève à l'hôpital de vannes
son tour et peut-être sa carrière aussi
pour d'autres comme bartoli l'italien la
coupe continue mais pour la victoire
d'étape c'est râpé rap et aussi pour les
français qui l'avait pourtant animé
françois simon échappée puis repris à
cinq kilomètres de l'arrivée
ou encore nicolas jalabert frère de
laurent qui tente sa chance dans
derniers mètres sans succès car
l'arrivée se joue au sprint et c'est
l'allemand erik zabel qui s'imposent
victoire d'étape maillot vert du
classement par points est 2e place au
classement général à 14 secondes qui
pollinisent pour abel et titres émis au
moins c'est une bonne journée